salve a tutti io volevo cominciare
raccontando un pochino la mia storia
personale e volevo cominciare con un
ricordo il ricordo di mio padre che
fingeva di lavorare per l'asilo che
frequentavo spostando inutilmente dei
mattoni da una parte all'altra cercando
di rassicurare le mie paure di essere
abbandonato tuttavia queste paure
peggiorarono un pochino quando all'età
di otto anni
quel furfante di mio padre ci abbandono
davvero portato via da un cancro al
fegato non ancora quarantenne
ed ecco che ed ecco che qualche medico
dell'ospedale di roma del dominio su di
sé che queste mie paure sarebbero
svanite con il naturale scorrere del
tempo
io col tempo imparai a trasformare
queste mie paure in una curiosità nella
curiosità di cercare di capire come far
muovere gli oggetti attorno a me in
quanto qualora mi avessero seguito non
avrebbero più abbandonato ricordo che
all'età di 11 anni ed esempio era messo
in testa di fare un sottomarino allora a
rabat hai un tubo un del sughero un
motorino una pila
ed ecco qui che volevo provare questo
sottomarino cominciare a trovarlo per
casa però ad un certo punto la nonna non
era in casa e abilità geniale di
riempire il congelatore di casa e la
nonna non era affatto contenta in quanto
ha dovuto bussare gran parte materiale
acquisito durante l'anno
oggi io sono ricercatore mi occupo di
locomozione la locomozione e quella
straordinaria capacità che gli oggetti
anno di muovere anche anno per per
muoversi e in particolare mi occupo di
locomozione per robot umanoidi robot
umanoidi
e chiaro che se parliamo di robot
umanoidi non possiamo non parlare di
umani e infatti gli esseri umani si
spostano nell'ambiente circostante
grazie alla camminata che è quella
straordinaria capacità che noi
acquistiamo nei primi 15 mesi di vita
essendo riflettiamo questa capacità la
qui siamo in un breve in un tempo
relativamente breve rispetto alla
lunghezza media di una vita di un essere
umano
ed ecco che
ed ecco che la domanda che sorge
naturale perché perché gli esseri umani
camminano come camminano beh allora qui
c'è poco da inventare e molto da
studiare quanto la biologia evolutiva ci
insegna che bisogna fare un salto
indietro nel tempo di 6 milioni di anni
e tornare sulla terra che era sottoposta
ad un abbassamento delle temperature
questo abbassamento delle temperature ha
indotto a sua volta una riduzione delle
foreste pluviali e quindi se voi
immaginate di essere uno scimpanzé che
vive ai bordi di queste foreste avreste
non necessità di muovervi di più questa
esigenza di muoversi quando quando
prendeva quando avveniva quando avveniva
sugli alberi e ha probabilmente indotto
un adattamento posturale eretto infatti
si dimostra che sceglie rango tango
reagiscono alla flessibilità dei rami
esattamente estendendo le gambe poi
l'altra esigenza del muoverci
probabilmente ha ottimizzato l'energia
l'energia spesa per la locomozione e
quindi se dovessimo sintetizzare
correndo è possibile che ci siano due
elementi fondamentali che hanno indotto
la camminata bipede come la viviamo oggi
e la manipolazione all'energia
ora probabilmente probabilmente la
manipolazione e ciò che ha indotto
l'intelligenza e l'intelligenza ci ha
fatto pure altre domande l'altra domanda
è ma possiamo spostarci più velocemente
da un punto all'altro
ed ecco che abbiamo inventato un certo
numero di sistemi questo starci che
vanno dalla dalla ruota fine robot
umanoidi però uno degli obiettivi
fondamentali di questi sistemi
soprattutto soprattutto gli stranieri
era la velocità spostarci velocemente ed
è per questo che abbiamo concepito delle
soluzioni assai diverse da quelle
concepite dalla natura
di certo gli aerei volano non sbattendo
le ali tuttavia quello che alle volte
possiamo possiamo non capiamo è se
abbiamo fatto meglio o peggio della
natura beh se noi prendiamo ad esempio
il blackboard che è uno degli aerei più
veloci mai concepiti dell'essere umano
ci rendiamo conto che raggiunge velocità
di un km al secondo
e se lo compariamo con un piccione
semplice il viaggio 34 metri al secondo
sembrerebbe che noi abbiamo fatto meglio
ma in realtà se noi scegliamo un'altra
unità di misura che la lunghezza porco
corpo sia puntiamo quante volte la
lunghezza del proprio corpo si ripete in
un secondo
ci rendiamo conto che la natura è ancora
avanti ai nostri sistemi di locomozione
e quello che noi cerchiamo di fare
allestito italiano di tecnologia e
convogliare tutta la conoscenza sui
sistemi di locomozione nei prossimi
sistemi che saranno in grado di muoversi
come i robot umanoidi beh è chiaro che
se vogliamo far muovere un robot
umanoide come un essere umano
bisogna il viaggio è lungo il legge luca
in quanto gli esseri umani sono
estremamente capaci di spostarsi
nell'ambiente circostante attraverso i
contatti tra tra il proprio corpo e
l'ambiente
e se noi compariamo queste capacità che
l'essere umano ha con i risultati
attuali della robotica umanoide beh ci
rendiamo conto che il viaggio è ancora
lungo ad esempio la darpa barbara
challenger che l'olimpiade dei robot ha
dimostrato che la camminata è ancora un
problema aperto e non è assolutamente di
facile risoluzione
ed ecco che prima prima di implementare
algoritmi di controllo per far muovere
dei robot umanoidi bisogna capire che
cos'è la camminata
beh la camminata quella straordinaria
capacità che noi abbiamo per muoverci e
forse non ce ne rendiamo conto ma noi
camminiamo cadendo ed infatti la
camminata può essere decomposta in tre
componenti fondamentali la prima
l'equilibrio l'equilibrio è davvero la
componente fondamentale
gli esseri umani passando da quadrupedia
bipedi hanno ottimizzato la propria
energia possono utilizzare le mani però
sono diventati instabili e poi ci sono
altre due componenti il moto
oscillatorio della gamba che cerca di
cercare il contatto e poi il modo
repulsivo ossia quel che la moto di
contrazione della gamba fondamentale
durante la corsa e dove implementiamo
noi questi algoritmi di camminata beh
quello che noi vogliamo implementare noi
vogliamo implementare questi algoritmi
su robot umanoide di nome aicab a cabo
robot umanoide atto all'incirca poco più
di un metro pesa all'incirca 30 30 kg ed
è dotata di un certo numero di sensori
il senso è più sensori come la visione
che gli permettono di vedere il
microfono che gli permettono di dire ma
soprattutto due sensori particolari che
sono la pelle ossia se vuoi toccato il
robot lui alla percezione di dove lo
state toccando e anche i sensori di
forza i sensori di forza ci permettono
di capire con quanta forza
noi stiamo toccando il robot e proprio
queste forze interne del robot in realtà
genero i movimenti ossia le
accelerazioni e come generano queste che
emulano in qualche modo la contrazione
muscolare dell'essere umano
se noi controlliamo dei muscoli stiamo
facendo delle forze interne e quelle
forze interne ora io io rimango in piedi
perché sto contrando sto controllando le
interazioni con l'ambiente esterno ed
ecco che se io voglio controllare un
robot in modo tale che esso sia in piedi
devo controllare le interazioni fra
robot e ambiente esterno
queste considerazioni possono far
nascere e che con ccc ci permettono di
concepire gli algoritmi di controllo per
il robot umanoide aicab è la cosa
fondamentale di questi algoritmi è che
il robot sia cedevole compliant cosa
significa significa che un interazione
con il robot non deve innanzitutto far
sì che il robot
ma certamente non deve ferire
l'operatore e questa è una delle
componenti fondamentali per delle
applicazioni che un giorno probabilmente
saranno nelle case nelle case di tutti
ora
ora è chiaro che l'equilibrio è
certamente una componente fondamentale
ma per camminare abbiamo bisogno
qualcosa in più e come possiamo
concepire algoritmi di camminata e
allora qui ci sono anni di letteratura
che ci spiegano come fare
come per cercare di far camminare un
robot
però se noi semplifichiamo il robot in
uno degli strumenti che probabilmente ha
rivoluzionato la scienza come il pendolo
allora una prima indicazione di dove
mettere il piede può essere quella
posizione dove il pendolo si ferma
esattamente in posizione verticale
beh allora questa semplice osservazione
ci permette di fare di di concepire
degli algoritmi di controllo per robot
umanoidi dandogli la possibilità di
spostarsi nello spazio tuttavia noi come
ricercatori abbiamo la necessità di
andare oltre non solo dal punto di vista
pratico ma anche teorico e quindi la
domanda che bisogna porsi ok
cosa possiamo immaginare dopo e possiamo
immaginare un robot sommozzatore ad
esempio in grado di operare in
condizioni assai difficili
oppure un robot ibrido che invece di
avere le gambe a delle ruote però ancora
una volta se voi dovreste chiedere a me
come immagina il futuro dei robot
umanoidi beh non posso non immaginare un
futuro dove questi robot siano in grado
di volare e consentendoci di spostarci
in modo senza paura è il modo
decisamente meno ossessivo compulsivo
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]